growing up I always saw the world
differently than others my teachers they
didn't understand me they said I had
problems I was never the cool kid in
school I didn't really fit in anywhere
but mama you sheltered me and helped me
believe then I got in the real world and
they tried to tear me down they tried to
take away my dreams and make me like
them wish I can turn back time to the
good old days where my momma sang us
believe but now I'm stressed out wish I
could turn back time to the good old
days when my mom was
us believe but now I'm stressed I used
to play pretend wrap my dreams upon the
wall play ball in the spring and
policemen in the fall I'd be the next
bill Gates there laughing in my face
saying wake up you need to make money oh
I used to play pretend wrap my dreams up
on the wall play ball in the spring and
policemen in the ball I be the next bill
Gates there laughing in my face saying
wake up you need to make money oh mama
I'm stronger now you taught me you saved
me there's nothing they could throw at
me that will hold me back this is my
life not theirs I'll live it on my terms
mama thank you for helping me believe